so another weekend goes by and more
serious questions about the stability of
President Trump over the weekend Donald
Trump used some horrible dog whistles
about mostly black Baltimore being
infested and of course people reacted to
that and we'll discuss that separately
and I I'm thinking my take on it may be
a little different than much of what has
been around over the last couple of days
but once again in the big picture Donald
Trump is reacting extraordinarily
erratically to the growing reality that
the congressional push for impeachment
has been reinvigorated a judge has now
been asked to release grand jury
evidence from Robert Moeller's
investigation more than 100 Democrats in
the House now supports an impeachment
inquiry against Donald Trump which I am
also going to talk about later and
Donald Trump went on a nearly 24-hour
tweet storm completely unhinged we've
seen to our Twitter storms we've seen
even like 10 or 12 hour ones if I recall
correctly but this was something new all
together now can anybody take the phone
away from Donald Trump it doesn't seem
like that's the case can anybody talk
sense into Donald Trump about these
tweets no I don't know that it's
necessarily seen as a problem because
even though these tweets that I'm about
to show you exposed that we have an
unstable president are dozens of tweets
where social media has now become the
equivalent for Donald Trump of a guy
ranting in the subway while urinating
under the stairs I am going to make the
case that actually these tweets serve a
purpose for Donald Trump aside from the
content which is to continue setting the
agenda and the narrative at the
exclusion of other topics and I'm going
to get to that in a little bit so let's
get to some of the tweets that Donald
Trump sent out this is just a sampling
Donald from starting with from the
bottom up in chronological order
congressman Elijah Cummings has been a
brutal bully shouting and screaming at
the great men and women of border patrol
about conditions at the southern border
when actually his Baltimore district is
far worse and more dangerous his
district is considered the worst in the
USA has proven last week during a
congressional tour the border is clean
efficient and well-run
very crowded Cummings district is a
disgusting rat and rodent infested mess
if he spent more time in Baltimore maybe
he could help clean up this very
dangerous and filthy place why is so
much money sent to the Elijah Cummings
district when it is considered the worst
run and most dangerous anywhere in the
United States no human being would want
to live there where is all this money
going how much is stolen investigate
this corrupt mess immediately and then
continuing consideration is being given
to declaring an Tifa the gutless radical
left whack jobs who go around hitting
only non fighters people over the heads
with baseball bats a major organization
of terror
along with ms-13 and others would make
it easier for police to do their jobs
going on the Democrats were trying
mightily to revive the badly and
irrevocably tarnished witch-hunt hoax
until robert muller put on the greatest
display of ineptitude and incompetence
that the halls of congress has ever seen
continuing the Dems are now coming out
of shock from the terrible molar
performance and are starting to spin
impeachment all over again how sick and
disgusting and bad for our country such
a big victory for our country
supreme court approves trump
administration plan to use military
funds for the wall skipping over a few
you'll see that Donald Trump continued
this rant saying we gave Nadler and his
Trump hating Dems the complete molar
report we didn't have to and even Muller
himself but now that both were a total
bust
they say it wasn't good enough nothing
will ever be good enough for them witch
hunt no collusion no obstruction total
exoneration Democrat witch-hunt
then he retweeted a bunch of Fox News
videos and continued tweeting about
various quotes regarding Robert molars
testimony talking again about
congressman Elijah Cummings who's been
able to do so little for the people of
Baltimore
statistically Baltimore ranks last in
almost every major category cummins as
thus Cummings has done not nothing but
milk Baltimore dry but the public is
getting wise to the bad job that he's
doing and then going into conspiracies
the real collusion
the conspiracy the crime was between the
Clinton campaign the DNC fusion GPS
Christopher Steele and many others
including Comey McCabe Lisa Paige and
her lover or and his wonderful and then
he continues to go on with that getting
into more conspiracies about the
Democrats are doing the Russians dirty
work and on and on and on in truly
stunning fashion and then lastly quoting
random people from Fox and friends
including you'll notice at the top of
your screen Pete hagseth who said Elijah
Cummings has had his chance to address
it crime and conditions in Baltimore for
decades and he hasn't gotten it done so
endless I mean a total of nearly thirty
tweets this is the President of the
United States aside from the content of
his tweets which is insane aside from
the amount of time that he's spending
tweeting the level of Rage that this man
is exhibiting towards just everyone is a
sign that Donald Trump is very worried
if and when Donald Trump's finances
really start to be dug into by Democrats
in the House and we're getting very
close to that I believe that Donald
Trump is going to go to the neck to the
next level this is a level which we
still have not seen and to be very clear
this is going to be a level where all
bets are off
I mean it's Trump going to start
actually calling people the n-word I
don't know he might he just might I
don't know whether Trump has the
restraint not to do almost anything that
we might imagine if and when it gets to
that point now there is another
hypothesis that I was reading about
which might explain these extended tweet
storms by Donald Trump it may be that
the legal staff either personal lawyers
or White House lawyers have started to
tell Trump listen there's a chance you
get indicted if you don't get reelected
in 2020 I don't know how they'd couch it
I don't know what language they would
use to explain this to Donald Trump it's
all still very speculative but it is not
outside the realm of possibility that
Donald Trump is starting to be warned by
his own legal team in
about listen molar is right by the
letter of the law you can be indicted
after leaving the White House winning in
2020 would be a sort of insurance policy
he likes to use that term but it would
be an insurance policy for him against
possible indictment if you think Donald
Trump is losing it now tweeting 30 times
in 20 18 hours or something like that
just remember that between now and 2020
there are any number of things that
could happen that will drastically
escalate Donald Trump beyond what we've
already seen and for his sake you'd
think someone on his staff would work to
take away Twitter access but it's maybe
easier said than done as we've known as
we've reported before and as we've we've
known based on a number of different
reports Trump will not even turn his
phone over for a security screening by
intelligence agencies 2020 Trump is a
trump that will be running believing
that it may take a win in 2020 to keep
him potentially out of prison okay that
is going to be a far crazier Trump than
we have ever seen and now I want to
focus in a little more specifically on
the Baltimore tweets